hi I'm Jeff Bryant I'll be giving a talk
with Jose Marti Nasia with about
eclipses and we're going to be giving a
presentation concerning the microsite
that we put together that highlights the
2017 total solar eclipse visible through
most of North America so this summer we
were really lucky to have a solar
eclipse so close to home so it was a
major event here in the US so here at
the World Forum we decided to do
something about it and we called it the
precision Eclipse project and put this
bigger it had many parts so first of all
we started by improving our own Astro
functionality also the date and time
related functionality because in order
to do astronomical computations you need
precise timing and careful treatment of
several types of type systems we did a
lot of research on the theory and
history of solar eclipses and in
particular Steven got really interested
in the history of solar eclipses and how
humanity has been able to get a more and
more precise predictions of of eclipses
then we did an independent computation
of contact times for the clips this a
bit of what we will describe later
Steven wrote a blog Jeff also wrote two
blocks you have links there and Jeff
will talk about them later we produced
the precision eclipse dot-com microsite
in which you were able to get all these
x and maps and more interesting
information and we also with all the
information we had collected we also had
the a notebook with related information
in the microsite so many things so the
problem the talk is that I'm going to
talk about first the first part and then
Jeff is going to talk about the second
part of my list of topics here
okay so if you want to make predictions
about eclipses what do you need so you
need basically three main ingredients
first you need to have good data for the
position of the Sun the earth and the
moon we need ephemeris data precise
enough second you need good orientation
on the earth and third you need a
careful way of linking those two things
with time information taking into
account things like final speed of light
so fortunately nasa provides very
precise data for the positions of moon
planets even spacecraft and these can
all be collected in what they call
kernels and they also provide software
to interface to those kernels etc there
is a link here to go and get some of
those so what I've done here is rather
than then interfacing with those kernels
in real time because they are huge what
I've done is just to extract some
interpolation functions which contain
the information that we will need so
these interpreting functions report the
positions of the Sun the earth and the
moon in a three-dimensional coordinate
system which is called a J 2000
coordinate system and the units are
astronomical units so this is quite
quite precise and then to do the
computations there are some other
numbers we need like the sound radius
the moon reduce the Earth's semi-major
axis etcetera right and it's all in
astronomical units
or here astronomical units per second
okay some basic facts is that of course
the earth is moving and moving around
the Sun like 30 km/s the moon is moving
around the earth speed of about one
kilometer per second and for example
these numbers coincide with what we get
from our function so I'm asking here
what's the norm of the vector between
the moon that's second twenty thousand
twenty thousand one I forgot to say that
I'm going to be measuring time from sec
seconds in in GMT time from 1200 to 2400
so this there is an axis of 43 200
seconds right and and the clips here
happened around two thousand twenty
thousand seconds and so this is this is
an axis of time in seconds from 12 hours
GMT time that day something also
interesting to know is that this the
rotations are all happening basically in
the same direction so so the earth is
going around the Sun in this direction
the earth is also rotating around it
selling in in the same direction the
moon is rotating around the earth in the
same direction and rotating around same
direction so this is a manipulate that
allows you to zoom and see the cones of
shadows etc but I don't have time to do
that so I leave it here for you to play
with it as I said something fundamental
is the control on time and there is a
basic problem in all of this the basic
problem is that there are two systems of
times which are important in this game
first in astronomy you need an
homogeneous axis of time that in which X
each second is the same one it counts
second and a second and a second for
Earth the important thing the civil time
is the rotation of the earth but
unfortunately the earth is slowing down
in its rotation actually when it was
created long ago billions of years ago a
day was just a few hours say five six
hours since then it's slowing down
progressively progressively and the
measurements currently say that it's
losing like two milliseconds per century
it's late
so so therefore that DT so it is the
number of days in a century so each day
is losing that amount if we now count
one of those amounts the first day of
the century
two of those amounts the second day of
the century etc it's they we end up with
this number and if we if we replace the
numbers that that means that each
century is 21 sorry 31 seconds longer
than the previous century and this is
something that accumulates so so in
order to have a synchronization between
the astronomical time and the civil time
we need to add the so-called leap
seconds so in order to have these under
control a number of time systems have
been introduced that is atomic in the
international atomic time which is
controlled by by by atomic clocks there
is a terrestrial time which is the time
used by astronomers which is just this
shift constant shift with respect to the
previous one UT one which is a time that
is following the Sun and then UTC I mean
the Sun in the sense of the rotation of
the earth so it's not homogeneous
because it's slowing down with the earth
and then UTC which is a time that has
been created to be always a number of
seconds shifted from time but that
number of seconds changes with time so
these are they they dip seconds at the
end the whole thing comes out to this
formula in which you have the relation
between these two fundamental times the
time of astronomers the times of the
rotation of the earth the difference is
Delta T and we have this difference Plus
this thing which is measure every day
and there's a web page where you can get
information about it and they are
actually do predictions and they
predicted that for that day of the
Eclipse it would be that amount so in
finally you put it this time so this
means that if we go to NASA space they
will report things in tt-time but when
we were looking at our watches it was
this time so this is the correction that
we had to measure and this correction is
included in all the formulas that I have
here so we don't have to worry about it
but if you don't worry about this you
would get all the times like 70 seconds
wrong well the the Eclipse has this area
so that's the Sun that's the moon the
earth will be kind of here and if the
earth happens to be in this smaller
earlier here we would have a total
eclipse of the of the Sun here if you
are looking from here you have a partial
eclipse of the Sun and if you are
looking from somewhere here you have an
annular eclipse of the Sun fortunately
we were very close to the apex of the
cone but we were on this side and so we
had a total eclipse of the Sun
now these are polygons that you may have
seen in reported so this is this was the
the partiality area so if you're wearing
one of these places you would see a
partial eclipse of the Sun if you were
in this band here you would see a total
eclipse of the Sun so the first question
is why does it have this weird shape
well in a north of Rafic projection it
looks better but still why for example
this part here and why this is kind of
waving etc so they would understand this
is I think it is this one so they this
is the earth it will be rotating we are
looking from the Sun so the earth is
rotating the the moon is passing in
front of us and now look how the this
central point here is the total area
sorry that the Umbra so the the this is
the pointing from which you would see a
total eclipse of the Sun this is the
penumbra cone so this from any of these
other points you would see a partial
eclipse of the Sun and you see how this
is always touching the lower line and
this part this point is following this
this is not here so this this basically
explained what that happened explains
what that happened that day
okay
okay
now what about the orientation of the
earth again we need something that tells
us how the earth is oriented with
respect to the to the j2000 coordinate
systems that is used in astronomy so
fortunately again there is an organism
the IE RS that worries about these and
reports daily also the the rotation
matrix that you have to use to go from
one coordinate system the one of the
earth our datum ITR f00 used in
geography to the J 2000 coordinate
systems of the astronomers so have those
interpolating functions this the angle
of rotation this is the axis of rotation
so that's a matrix which is the
orientation so using this for example
this is a typical computation so so this
is the angle between the from our
location this is the angle between the
Sun and the moon and you see you have to
use all four functions the earth
position the orientation of the earth
the Sun function the same position and
the moon position every computation
related to eclipse needs a father and so
we can plot now that and this is in our
time axis from Champaign when it was the
moment of maximum eclipse when the Sun
and the moon were aligned
however this angle is too large here we
always saw partial eclipses not a total
eclipse unfortunately this computation
is actually wrong because it's not
taking into account the fact that the
speed of light is finite so we need a
bit of more of computation so we need a
fixed point computation that takes into
account that there are large distances
that the speed of light is finite and
recomputes time again and again until it
converges and so for example to do a
computation of where is the Umbra center
we have to do that and so for example if
I don't do that iterate sorry doing that
iteration I get given your position for
a given time the time that was reported
for for Calvin Dayal maximum Eclipse
however if I do only one iteration which
means
it doesn't do any tradition at all the
the position reported is the other one
and I will be making an error of 22
might so it will be this so this is the
the path of totality
that's Carbondale these is the center
that we get if we do the computation
correctly this is the center that we get
if we do everything correctly
except for taking into account the speed
of light which is shifted and we can do
that for many many centers for for for
many many times during the clips and we
get there with that simple function we
get you see where the center of the
total part was every five minutes okay
so yep so now so now this is Jeff's part
[Applause]
okay well as you can tell Jose did a lot
of math work my parts going to be a
little bit more pretty to look at maybe
not quite so complicated we actually
this was a very large team effort it was
not just me and Jose Jose did a lot of
the backend math but we actually had
some members of our web team in house
that actually did a lot of the
deployment but we actually were able to
deploy the precision Eclipse Eclipse
computation website precision Eclipse
comm where you just go there kind of
like on how often you just get an input
field but the intent is you put your
location in put an address you could put
a city most people probably just put in
their city but it would even work if
you're on your mobile phone and you
could actually would actually have a
button that allows you to get your GPS
location and it would give you a
personalized report for that particular
location at the times of the eclipse
this is the front page
there we go and once you enter a
location so here for example this was
the result for champagne
you get a report there's a number of
panels here the top left panel there
shows you the the location where you
currently are where you made the query
from and champagne in this case you can
see the path of totality going down and
to the left right there and then I'm
more of a zoomed out view kind of
showing you nationally where is that
with relation to the whole path as it
goes then over here it's basically just
a text report kind of giving you precise
times partial eclipse begins and how
long it lasts Jose mentioned here in
Champaign we didn't get a total eclipse
so we can't really say much about how
long did totality last best we can do is
tell you how long partiality lasted so
but then below that we get kind of a
time sequence here showing how much of
the tether the Sun is covered at what
times and you can see here down here
just below the diagram you can see we've
got the actual time so partial eclipses
started here in Champaign at 11:53 a.m.
we had our maximum eclipse which was
about 93 percent I believe and partial
eclipses entered at 244 and then down
below a little bit sorry I'm not used to
max here there we go we get a little bit
more extended time sequence kind of
showing the progression of the Eclipse
as it should have appeared for the
location you queried for this was all
made possible from Jose's math behind
the scenes
now other locations that's an example of
partiality you've got a very similar
report so this is a this is for
Carbondale Carbondale would keep
mentioning because Carbondale Illinois
is the was the peak of the the total
solar eclipse anywhere in the nation
that was where you were going to get the
absolute longest eclipse anywhere not by
huge amounts I mean anywhere along the
path of totality you would have seen
something that was about two and a half
minutes long but Carbondale was the kind
of a technical computed maximum another
point of interest is that in seven years
there will be another total solar
eclipse that will also go through
Carbondale so if you were in Carbondale
you're actually going to be at this
prime location for to follow up eclipses
but in Carbondale you can see here the
time of the Eclipse we have a little bit
more detail here
because totality shown here began at one
oh sorry
120 and ended at 122 so we're a little
after so about two and a half minutes
there and you get the actual times for
that but other than that it's basically
the same kind of visual representation
that we got for the partial eclipses
except that you can see the Sun got
totally blocked so that's the general
report that you would get from an
eclipse query now how did we assemble
these things well
the maps panel is obviously done with
Geographics so you know once you've got
a given geo position here we've got
Carbondale once again used as an example
very small amount of code is needed to
actually construct that map you can see
that we've got a geo marker that shows
you the user's location and then we're
using the function and Wolfram language
solar eclipse to just give you the total
phase polygon that we use as an overlay
to Geographics to show you the path now
that's just a basic interpretation the
exact implementation used a custom geo
marker here that you can see that's just
a graphics primitive that was just drawn
you can use any custom Geographics
marker you want just by drawing a
graphics primitive and then you can hook
it up so if you're interested that's in
the talk you can look at that closer but
then it's just a slight modification
though of what we did up above where you
just put in your custom graphics code
there for my pin how to align it and
then of the other map panel was just a
zoomed in version of that so basically
all we did was change the geo range to
50 miles using zoom down on that
location that covered the maps panel
now the biggest thing that you want to
compute for an eclipse is the timings
that's that's the important part that we
were going for here try to be as precise
as possible and so typically when people
who deal in eclipses they refer to the
Kotton - for contact points and they
call them usually C 1 C 2 C 3 and C 4
here in Champaign all we had was
partiality so you had the point where
the moon first touched the Sun that's C
1 and then it just kind of drifted just
a little bit north here in Champaign it
drifted north of the south edge of the
Sun and then it disappeared so we had C
1 and C 4 just the point where the moon
first touched and the point where the
moon just barely left
those are C 1 and C 4 but if you're in
totality you also get C 2 and C 3 and
this is where keep in mind during a
total eclipse the moon is just slightly
larger or exactly the same size as the
Sun so typically there's a time frame
where it you know the moon is just on
top of the Sun and it takes just a few
minutes for it to move over and then
it's gone
so totality doesn't last anywhere near
as long as partiality does so but if
you've got a total solar eclipse you can
actually compute the contact points the
second and third contact points and
that's what we were going for and in
visualizing this we ran into an
interesting thing that we hadn't
anticipated basically Jose did all the
hard work of computing what times things
should be what's the position of the Sun
in the moon - very precise values so we
got the altitude NASA myth for a given
location of the Sun in the sky and then
we went to plot it so here you can see
we've done a calculation here where
we've got you know the date object at a
certain time the time that we want to
investigate we've computed the moon's
position and the sun's position at that
time we've got the sun's radius and the
moon's radius and we basically assign
plot these as disks with graphics so as
you can see here there's just a graphics
head and then we've got two colored
disks essentially but the time that
we've chosen was actually supposed to
have been after the moon had contacted
yet when we plot it they're not even
touching each other we thought we had a
big problem what's wrong with their code
why is the moon not touching the Sun it
turns out at all
a problem with projections graphics does
not do any projected projections it
actually takes place on a flat plane but
the sky is more like a dome if you don't
take that into account it actually
throws things off so we ended up
switching using the exact same disks but
we switched to geo disk and then
Geographics and there you go
using the exact same computed values
it's just too dependent on how you plot
it you've got to take that projection
into account where it will be off so
that's actually it was a very important
part in getting that visualization to
work Geographics is your friend now the
white version here this is just a
subtlety here we had two different
versions of the visualization on the
microsite one had a white background
where you don't see all the moon you
only see the part covering the Sun we're
actually using a thick white circle
right here to act like a mask that
covers up the rest of moon outside the
Sun so that's how we got the white
background there for the black
background when we actually did want to
see the moon so there we just don't use
the we just dark background I don't know
if you could actually see that with the
contrast on the screen there but the
moon the incomplete disk of the moon is
visible there just slightly darker than
the background of the graphic
all right
so that's basically how we summarized it
we are planning do we have a link to D
and C you want to talk about the geek
notebook a little bit okay okay we
actually also something else we had on
the micro site is we had this kind of an
additional information notebook that it
was presented so if you're interested in
eclipses you might be interested in
these other things and this is available
if you go to the micro site which is
still live you can still go there and
use it even though the Eclipse is past
and once you're done you go to the
bottom of the report and there's a thing
about full details and if you go to the
full details there's a whole bunch of
additional calculations that we put in
here that you might be interested in how
eclipses are carried out how plots were
done things like that I encourage you
all to visit that there's it's it's
pretty detailed there's some pretty
complex calculations in here so we've
got you know various ways of plotting in
Geographics your location we've got
actually a an API call to the microsite
so you can actually generate the grid of
contact times yourself locally how to
generate eclipse maps for a particular
state that are annotated with x plotting
the light curve this is essentially I
think this was obscuration was this
obscuration or do you remember which
okay so there's a subtle difference
between obscuration and man magnitude
okay so it's that was the obscuration
and we've also got get the distance to
the location of so how far are you from
the distance of maximum duration we've
even got some Wolfram Alpha calls here
to generate star chart showing you what
this guy should look like
obviously the Moon and Sun are on top of
each other so you should get a solid red
disc for time of totality even some
slightly unrelated things we've got data
on what's the sunspot count where I was
at observing the Eclipse we actually had
people that were observing Sun well
before the Eclipse started looking at
sunspots and doing all kinds of stuff
and then we've got some really
complicated stuff explicitly solving the
main lunar problem numerically and I'm
not gonna go too much into detail here
I'll kind of leave this as homework for
you guys but this is something at a
Michael trot and I know Jose we're both
heavily involved in it kind of goes into
the details of how you actually solve
using nd solve things like the location
of the moon shape of the moon's orbit
you need to wrap up here I think we're
basically done so oh very quickly I'll
leave this for most you to go through
his homework but if you have any
questions me and Jose are both going to
be around there's lots of astronomy
questions I'm sure that could come out
of this so uh thank you
[Applause]